[Musique]
vrai bug sap a été le passage de 99 à
2000 oui c'est ce qu'ils avaient annoncé
oui ou les ordinateurs tous nos pays
devaient se planter certains avaient la
fin du monde est situé non le vrai bug
c'est quand en fin 2019
on a dit pour 2020 bonne année oui ma
dernière tempête en date la crise
sanitaire qui met le gouvernement sous
pression depuis bientôt un an
mais emmanuel macron ne faiblit pas dans
les sondages
mieux il progresse avec 41% d'opinions
favorables le président français gagne
trois points de popularité et atteint
ainsi son meilleur score depuis six mois
[Applaudissements]
on peut aller chez papi et mamie à noël
on ne mange pas avec eux on coupe la
bûche de noël en deux papiers mamie
manche dans la cuisine et nous sommes en
jeu dans le dans la salle à manger
youpi c'est bientôt noël le sapin les
jours et les retrouvailles
vraiment très bizarre papy et mamie vont
venir à la maison pour le réveillon tu
aimes ton papier tamami alors par quel
est dans la cuisine
si tu ne veux pas qu'il finisse avec de
gros tuyaux par cloud qui rejoint que
fer rouge
dormez vous dormez vous sort ni les
clochettes sont nés les clochettes aux
etats-unis la situation allait toujours
dramatique ça n'a pas empêché 7000
personnes sans masque sans distanciation
physique de se réunir dans une synagogue
de new york pour le mariage du petit
fils d'un rabbin évidemment pour chanter
danser et célébrer ce mariage
le gouverneur de l'état a fait part de
son indignation
ça m'aidait à ménéz
on va
[Musique]
il ya deux choses vraiment qu'ils qui
m'agace il part à la télévision c'est
pas ça le plus dangereux
et quand la télévision vous répondre
voici l'instant ferry du 24 novembre
m
[Musique]
le 11 novembre dernier à bord d'un vol
entre moscou et ekaterinbourg alors que
le vol suit son cours normal soudain les
deux pilotes décident de changer de
trajectoire avec leur boeing 737 il
dessine volontairement un pénis comme on
le voit sur les images radar le dessin
est parfaitement tracé grâce à la
trajectoire de l'avion
une performance qui a causé quand même
un retard de 20 minutes qui nous ont
fait rire la compagnie qui a ouvert une
enquête
alors pour vous donner un ordre de
grandeur un ordre de grandeur lancé ne
rit pas pourquoi a dessiné un pénis dans
le ciel au delà de la performance
artistique et bien selon les premiers
éléments il s'agit d'un message de
soutien adressée à artem dzyuba c'est le
capitaine de l'équipe russe de foot qui
a été sanctionné après l'apparition sur
les réseaux d'une vidéo où on le voit se
masturber bref il y avait un message
derrière ce pénis dans le ciel dit donc
c'était aux frasques un grec dont qui a
baptisé cette plante orchidées à partir
de requis lyon testicules tout
simplement parce que les racines de ces
orchidées terrestre possédée petit qu
une tubercule qu'on peut assimiler
voilà mais j'adore maintenant je veux
dire arrête de me casser les orchidées
ou parce que je peux tu toi tu peux tout
faire
radio atteint un niveau physique
la tête madame c'est pas vous qui prenez
les décisions est ce que vous pourriez
peut-être nous dire si vous connaissez
ce cas oui peut-être le cas échéant nous
passer quelqu'un qui pourrait nous aider
pour ce jeune homme alors alors à suivre
la revue de presse
après il ya des lettres qui manque ce
matin la météo là ça va mais d'abord à
bahia les stylos qui sont vancia là
c'est une catastrophe
j'espère pour lui qu'il saura maintenir
le cap parce qu'en face il a un sacré
concurrent
[Musique]
bon ok c'est pas flagrant là à les
ravages du stress
comment es tu lucas
ah je crois que ma présence n'arrange
rien à l'occasion de ce grand jour
mais dit il est content de son projet
pro ça s'est super bien passé je pense
que voilà mais dupuis fait ces projets
et plus belle la confiance et plus ça se
passe meilleur ah oui j'avais commencé à
votre encontre
il avait remplacé la suite avec deux
louches bon maintenant il faut enchaîner
d'abord et malheureusement parce que je
viens de l'apprendre je voudrais faire
par l'assemblée de mon émotion en
apprenant la main la mort de une légende
du quinze de france
si jeune christophe dominici n'avait pas
50 ans